hello there internet uh i'm john oliver
our show is on hiatus right now so i'm
coming to you straight from youtube the
world's most dystopian video hellscape
before tick tock and
i'm here because i want to talk about
something near and dear to my let's say
heart and that is the da vinci cult the
2003 dan brown novel about solving art
crimes hornerly and
the subsequent 2006 ron howard film that
it spawned and believe me i already know
what you're thinking you're thinking i'm
riveted and i don't need an explanation
as to why you're talking about this book
18 years after its release i think it's
normal and good that you are doing this
and i assume that your take on it will
be measured and fair john you think john
you continue to think john
you're doing great please keep going
thank you
i am and i will
my chief gripe with this book and movie
is with the maddeningly simple solution
to the titular puzzle but before we go
it all in on that i do think it is
important to quickly cover the plot or
maybe not important but i'm going to do
it anyway because
this is free content on youtube which
means the only bar that needs to be
cleared when deciding whether or not
something gets in is do i feel like
talking about this and when it comes to
wasting your time with the plot of the
da vinci codes johnny's answer to that
is a big sloppy yes so
let's do this thing or hold on you don't
know what you're getting into yet
very basically here is the plot um an
old man named jacques sonier is murdered
in the louvre and with his dying breath
leaves a series of arch related puzzles
that only renowned symbologist not a job
by the way
robert langdon can solve clues that will
uncover a world-changing secret about
jesus christ that the catholic church
has kept buried for centuries now teamed
up with sonia's granddaughter sophie and
on the run from both interpol and a
radical sect of catholicism plus one
assassin that would like to keep this
secret buried at all costs robert
langdon is in a race against time to
travel all across europe and solve art
puzzles before it's too late
the titular puzzle corresponds to a
cryptex which holds a map to some
important evidence along the way there
are some double crossing by langton's
former friend an excruciating amount of
long-winded history lessons at least one
sexual ritual and paul betley's ass but
that is
very basically the plot of the da vinci
code essentially robert langton was the
only guy smart and horny enough to solve
a bunch of art puzzles the last of which
will uncover documents proving that
jesus christ was married and had a child
and at this point
i do feel it's important for me to tell
anyone watching this at home that the
studio audience did not sign up to be
here for this
they thought that they were attending a
normal taping of this show and not what
up to this point has been a mostly
jokeless summary of the plot of 2003's
the da vinci codes if you're sensing any
kind of tension in their confused tepid
and sometimes irritated responses just
know
you're probably right
they're not even allowed to look at
their phones and they won't be able to
do that for a while
so let's continue and i'm going to get
to the puzzle part in a second but to
understand why it makes me so mad some
context
if you are too young to remember what
the world was like when da vinci code
came out first of all die
second though it is hard to overstate
just how huge this book about using art
to solve crimes and piss off the church
was it spent
136 consecutive weeks as a new york
times hardcover fiction bestseller it
sold more than 80 million copies
worldwide and was translated into 51
languages but look these are just
numbers if i've learned anything from
the da vinci code and believe me i
haven't it's that numbers can't tell us
anything the point here is the da vinci
code book was massively inescapably
successful and had a major impact on
culture at the time and the good news is
we are now just now arriving at my solo
point because
none of this success would really bother
me that much if it were not for the fact
that the cryptic at the heart of the da
vinci code the puzzle art throb robert
langdon has to solve involves a poem
that begins in london lies a knight a
pope in turd his labor's fruit a holy
wrath incurred now we quickly find out
the knight in question is sir isaac
newton so isaac newton
labour's fruit you're thinking apple
right apple it's your first guess and
it's also your only guess and you're
right because it's apple
no one should need robert langdon a
harvard educated puzzle solver who
to get to the bottom of this a child
could solve that puzzle and yet the poem
continues
you seek the orb the ought be on the
tomb
it speaks of rosy flesh and seeded womb
so orb
rosy flesh
seeds it's apple is it it's
apple guess how many pages there are
between that poem and the solution to
the puzzle i'll give you a clue it's a
lot more than one
both the book and the movie make it seem
like only the brilliant robert langton
could possibly decode the mystery behind
those complex words
here is the scene in the movie version
where he explains the solution like he's
indiana jones finding the arc of the
covenant to a speechless and
awestruck amelie there was every orb
conceivable on that tomb except
one
the orb which fell from the heavens
and inspired newton's life's work work
that incurred the wrath of the church
until his dying day
[Music]
a-p-p-l-e
apple
[Applause]
oh
i
i hate that he spells it out so much
my dad told me this book was good
everybody's dad did
did you know they made two da vinci code
movies well they didn't because guess
what they made three
and i recognize that it has been several
minutes since i've said anything that
could defensively can be considered
either relevant or a joke and if that
bothers you at all let me simply remind
you you don't have to be here these
people do they cannot leave
but you could have stopped watching this
10 minutes ago but no you chose not to
so don't be angry with me be angry with
yourself you let yourself down i'm doing
fine
and look
is this the most important story in the
world right now of course not of course
not it's at best the fourth most
important story i just genuinely think
that it is very weird that in 2003 this
stupid stupid book
took the planet by storm and i just
think enough time has passed that we can
talk about it now it was bad and it was
weird and the titular code was apple
a-p-p-l-e
now what was my point here am i trying
to suggest that our brief but intense
obsession with the da vinci code was a
metaphor something indicative of our
dangerous propensity for getting swept
up by comfortingly simple ideas lulling
us into a sort of group thing
no not really i just think this book is
bad i think
actually the best way to express my
frustration is in the language that da
vinci code enthusiasts can best
understand which is to say with a subtle
art related puzzle that an infant can
figure out will you please indulge me um
my problem with the da vinci code
separate from the fact that it is a
terrible book that absorbed the entire
post-911 world for no clear reason is a
mystery a mystery hidden somewhere
in this famous painting
a mystery
that only could be solved by a robert
langdon level genius
art
do you see it
take your s take your time can you solve
this puzzle
can you solve this complex puzzle
and unlock why i think the da vinci code
is so stupid it's subtle but
it's in there the dumbest thing about
the da vinci code and art all rolled
into one sound off in the comments below
if you've solved this complex riddle
in the meantime thank you so much for
watching that's our show we'll be back
in february we'll see you again then
apple
app le
you